SPEAKER 1: Let me show you
how to create your database
and run migrations using
App Engine Flux in Rails.
I've written an app, and
I'm using the MySQL2 gem
to connect to my database.
I've created a second generation
cloud SQL instance called
Rails instance.
And I set up the user
name and password
that my Rails app will use.
I've also downloaded
the cloud SQL proxy,
and I have it running
in the background.
To connect my Rails app
to my cloud SQL instance,
I need to get the
connection name from gcloud.
I use gcloud SQL instances
describe and then my instance
name.
And since I just need
the connection name,
I'll pipe that through grep.
I take the connection name and I
can put it in my database.yaml.
I also add the user name and
password while I'm in here.
So as the proxy is running,
I can set my Rails env
to production and I can use
my regular Rails commands
to run the database create
and database migrations.
Now I'm ready to deploy
my app to App Engine.
I hope this was helpful.